SETI is the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence and it addresses the
question are we alone in the universe
this is a question which was goes back
to the dawn of history but for most of
human history it's been in the province
of religion and philosophy 50 years ago
however it became part of science and
the trailblazing work of a young
astronomer named Frank Drake set the
trend Frank decided to start scanning
the skies with a large radio telescope
in the hope of stumbling across a
message from et it seemed a somewhat
quixotic enterprise when he began but
over the years it's grown and grown is
now an international effort and I think
it's taken seriously by many scientists
and so it really consists of using radio
telescopes choosing target stars where
it's conceivable there might be some
sort of advanced alien civilization and
hoping that they might be beaming radio
messages our way and so the the 50th
anniversary of this it seems to me a
good time to take stock because after
all we've had nothing but an eerie
silence in 50 years
so these astronomers have been patiently
pursuing this quest I might say Frank
Drake himself is still in the game 50
years on this is heroism of an unusual
sort who else do you know his devised a
scientific experiment and has pursued it
for 50 years got a null result and is
still smiling and optimistic so Frank
Drake is a great hero of mine and I
admire his zeal and positivism but it is
just an eerie silence and so the
question is are we doing the wrong thing
should we be looking somewhere else or
in some other way shall we broaden the
search and my conclusion is really that
I think what the SETI people are doing
is just great and I hope they go on
doing it and doing it better but
meanwhile we should start thinking
outside the proverbial box a bit to see
if there are other ways in which we
could try to track down et
if you ask the astronomers of the sharp
end of Seti why they think there has
been an eerie silence they'll say well
we only have been doing it for 50 years
we just started what more do you
expected to begin of us out there and in
fact to put that into context they
looked carefully at just a few thousand
stars there are four hundred billion
stars within our Milky Way galaxy alone
so it is a needle in the haystack search
of course it's easy to conclude simply
that they just haven't been doing it
long enough for hard enough it's no
surprise they haven't heard anything but
the alternative is that we are indeed
alone in the universe and it's
impossible to answer that question
because there are so many unknown
factors if we're looking for
intelligence in the universe I think
everybody assumes that this has to start
with life and so the question is how
likely is it that there will be life
elsewhere in the universe now when I was
a student almost nobody thought there
was any life beyond Earth today it's
fashionable to say that there's life all
over the place of the universe is
teeming with it but the scientific facts
on the ground haven't really changed
we're still just as ignorant as we were
40 or 50 years ago about how life began
got a very good theory of the evolution
of life once it gets started but it's
how did you get going in the first place
we we don't need a blow-by-blow account
of exactly how it got going on earth but
we would at least like to know whether
it's a very probable event or very
improbable event and in our present
state of ignorance we can't even pin
that down we can't even bracket the odds
could have been a stupendously
improbable fluke a freak chemical
accident that occurs just once in the
universe or it could be that life
emerges automatically and naturally as
part of the underlying scheme of things
maybe the universe has intrinsically
bio-friendly laws that brings life into
being all over the place we don't know
it's only fashion that has said the
pendulum has swung from extreme
skepticism about extraterrestrial life
to extreme extreme credulity the truth
is somewhere in between but to pin it
down we've really got to address that
question
likely is it that life will arise on an
earth-like planet I should say we know
that there are many many other Earth's
out there we're almost certain that
there would be upwards of a billion
earth-like planets in our galaxy alone
so there's no lack of real estate where
life might happen but what we don't know
is how likely it is given the real
estate given a wonderful pristine planet
like Earth how likely is it that life
will pop up and inhabit it we don't know
the answer to that